hey guys hope you're well Samuel leads
here and it is official I am going to be
starting all over again
to become financially free so if you've
not heard I'm gonna I've literally
posted this on my Facebook group so you
can check out the Facebook group and I
want to update everybody on YouTube so
you know what the rules are when I'm
doing this and also why I'm doing this
so here it is I'm going to read this
directly from my Facebook group it is
official on the 15th of November 2018
I'm going to become financially free all
over again starting with nothing
objective the objective is to build a
property income from scratch of 3000
pounds per month at least 50% of this
needs to be a passive residual income if
I run out of money and can't afford to
live or abandon the challenge without my
income I fail if I can prove to be
financially independent anytime after
starting with zero from scratch and then
demonstrate that I'm making 3000 pounds
per month through property I succeed the
purpose of this is because I want to
prove that anybody can achieve financial
freedom with the right knowledge and
anybody can become financially free
regardless of their circumstances no
excuses after writing and typing and
publishing these rules I now look at it
and think jeez maybe I was too strict on
myself but again I want to demonstrate
no excuses so these are the rules the
first rule of is 1 money
I cannot invest a penny of my own money
nor do I have access to my bank account
for anything to staff I cannot get any
of my staff to help or assist with this
challenge in any way apart from my
videographer who's gonna be there solely
to fill me 3 Network I cannot take a
penny from anybody in my existing
network any properties I buy or sell
have to be done from strangers due to my
name being quite well-known in the
property world I will be using an alias
for I'm allowed to travel as much as I
like but I'll have to sleep in a
location where I do not know anybody and
have zero properties currently this will
mean I'm based in an unknown territory
five I will be evicted from my hotel on
the 22nd of November unless I have made
money to pay for more nights six I will
begin the challenge with a brand new
bank account compliant property sourcing
account and a balance of zero and zero
credit rating for those that have asked
no I'm not going to screw up my credit
rating just for the challenge but I'm
not going to tap into any credit using
my existing credit rating at all I will
be supplied with one week worth of
clothes basic essentials and one week
box in a hotel room in the new foreign
location somewhere in England seven due
to my recovering kneecap an inability to
drive my wife and daughter will join me
for the challenge this will mean I have
also got to provide for them no other
friends or family can join me in the
challenge and eight if I succeed I'll
have to go over all the profits and
figures to a third party independent
professional who has experience with
finance and property they will assess
and decide if my success is satisfactory
in line with the original goals so
that's it so basically starting all over
again from scratch and if I fail I fail
I believe that there's lessons when you
fail so if I fail I fail if I succeed
which I really think I will I'm very
confident I'm gonna be able to become
financially free all over again in a
matter of weeks I don't know how many
weeks maybe six weeks 12 weeks I have no
idea but I'm confident about to do it
because of what I know and I've already
visualized exactly what's going to
happen even though I don't know where
I'm gonna be even though I have no money
I think I can just really see happening
so that's the challenge I love your
support and encouragement in this so if
you're going to be following then please
do let me know below your thoughts on
the challenge also please do share this
like crazy because you know the more
people that realize that it's not about
your current circumstances and anybody
can
create their own life for themselves and
become financially independent
regardless of where they're at right now
and regardless of whether they have
money or don't have money have credit
don't have credit where they are in the
country I think more people that wake up
to that then I think it's going to
really revolutionize revolutionize
people's lives and I need to make a big
difference in the country so that's why
I'm doing it so share it like crazy let
me know your thoughts below and if
you're not subscribed to my channel I'm
going to be doing probably daily but
very regular updates throughout the
challenge in November I'm also going to
be revealing of a city at some point I'm
going to pick one at random or something
worked exactly what I'm going to do yet
but that so yeah that's my week guys
love you lots and hope so season thank
you so much for watching if you
benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens
but whatever you do don't forget to
subscribe right here and I'll see you
next time